il y a quatre ans nous constations deux
visu la décrépitude de l'Hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont c'est des morceaux
ce sont détachés dans son 2 murs de
l'hôpital en 2018 on voulait donc
accélérer la reconstruction pour la
terminer au plus tard en 2025
l'espérance de 7 ans nous on voudrait
quand ça soit plus rapide mais le projet
pourrait s'étendre au moins jusqu'en
2032 mais est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir
terminer l'ensemble avant par exemple
ah c'est certain qu'il faut réussir cet
objectif la société québécoise des
infrastructures pense que ça pourrait
même s'étendre jusqu'en 2035 le projet
doit être revu puisque la facture
explose évaluer l'an passé à deux points
5 milliards le coût du projet a été
révisé à la hausse à 4,2 milliards les
vers dernier une augmentation de
68%. et Québec refuse pour l'instant
d'allonger la différence mais avec deux
points 6 milliards vous ne pouvez pas
faire la totalité de la réfection c'est
extrêmement difficile évidemment avec
l'augmentation des coûts puis les cours
mètres carrés on peut pas faire la
totalité de ce qui était prévu mais on
peut en faire beaucoup on pourrait donc
réduire la superficie du tiers et
procéder en plusieurs étapes c'est
certain que on veut faire la première
étape qui va répondre à 720d ça il y a
pas de doute plusieurs pensent que ce
sera carrément impossible 2.6 milliards
de façon réaliste n'est pas suffisant on
a besoin de plus d'argent que ça c'est à
peu près le coup que ça va coûter pour
l'hôpital qu'on construit actuellement
sur la Rive-Sud qui va être deux fois
plus petit que maison neuve Rosemont on
se met la tête dans le sable parce qu'il
y a 2,5 milliards c'est un pas cible
selon tous les calculs alors on est
peut-être plus près du 4.5 peut-être
même 5 milliards et plus on attend plus
ça se recharge autre défi onéreux
l'édifice principal qui est cruciforme
devrait être préservé parce qu'il aurait
une valeur patrimoniale les goûts sont
dans Nature chacun peut juger pour nous
ça reste notre vieux bâtiment qui tient
avec la broche nous on le voit beaucoup
plus à l'intérieur ou est-ce qu'il est
totalement désuet la reconstruction de
l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont et donc
plombé et par l'inflation comme bien
d'autres projets dans le domaine de la
santé qui doivent être révisés étant
donné l'explosion des coûts de
construction ici David Gentile
Radio-Canada Montréal